a bom gente a gente vai falar sobre a
doença de alzheimer hoje então o
alzheimer é uma doença neurológica
degenerativa que basicamente afeta as
funções cognitivas do cérebro da pessoa
que acaba por desenvolver ela matou as
células neurais e fazendo com que a
pessoa perde a capacidade de se
comunicar bem a complexidade de um
ambiente ea perda de memória recente
a gente não sabe exatamente o motivo
pela qual ela se envolve mas a gente
sabe muito bem as consequências do que
acontece então dentro do cérebro de uma
pessoa que desenvolveu essa doença a
gente pode perceber vários fatores entre
eles o acúmulo de uma de duas proteínas
uma chamada tau que acaba por entrar nos
neurônios e formando ver os
neurofibrilares e outro pelo acúmulo de
placas de proteína beta amilóide que
acaba de alguma forma matar o neurônio
impedindo assim a diminuir o volume
cerebral
então aqui a gente pode comparar um
cérebro e o cérebro com alzheimer
a gente pode muito bem ver que o volume
da massa tiveram que diminuir muito e
que a área do hipocampo ele é
severamente afetada área do campo pra
quem não sabe é que seria responsável
por armas armazenadas memórias
então a descoberta do alzheimer ocorreu
quando um psiquiatra alemão resolveu
fazendo crops do cérebro de uma mulher
que havia apresentado os sintomas
deveriam perder recente e tudo mais
durante os últimos três anos de vida
então ele botou no microscópio os
fragmentos do cérebro e ele percebeu que
os neurônios dessa região estavam muito
carregado dessas duas proteínas que eu
citei anteriormente
então ele foi vendo que estavam coisas
muitas coisas acontecendo ali naquele
lugar e que estão acontecendo de forma
errado
foi assim que descobriu a online bom eu
vou citá aos sintomas estudou design
ele é dividida em quatro tipos de
estágio inicial que apresenta perda de
memória a mudança de personalidade ea
pessoa esquece os lugares e palavras
conhecidas no segundo estágio apresenta
estação em insônia e dificuldade para se
comunicar
além de ter dificuldade de concentração
no terceiro estágio que é conhecido como
grave o mais importante para identificar
o alzheimer é apresenta dificuldade para
comer e incontinência fecal ou urinária
dificuldade para realizar tarefas
básicas e esquecimento de fatos pessoais
e algo importante que aconteceu na vida
e além disso tem uma força natural por
exemplo a pessoa que conversava muito
com os vizinhos e agora no se isola na
conversa mais e é isso
e além disso é uma parte bem triste é
que a pessoa não lembra mais dos entes
queridos e do rosto do que faziam quem
são as pessoas e no quarto estágio a
pessoa perde totalmente os movimentos e
não consegue mais se movimentar sem uma
ajuda de um familiar ou até mesmo de um
enfermeiro
os músculos por causa dela não conseguir
se movimentar e lhe trouxe atrofiam e os
reflexos que eu ficam a 2
a deglutição comprometida e ela perde
totalmente a consciência e atitude
então como explicado anteriormente a
gente ainda não possui informações
suficientes para determinar a causa
específica mas a gente sabe que o
alzheimer uma doença multifatorial então
muitas coisas precisam ocorrer dentro do
organismo para que ela se desenvolva
alguns fatores facilitam que tenha
doença como por exemplo possui um
cromossomo específico que pode ser dado
geneticamente o teu cérebro não realizar
uma limpeza dessas proteínas de forma
tão eficaz e ter uma facilidade maior de
ter uma informação ou coisa assim na
massa cerebral
bom como se realiza o tratamento como
vocês sabem alzheimer não tem cura
então os medicamentos que eles dão é só
pra inibir os sintomas e tentar melhorar
a qualidade de vida do paciente e da
família também
além de tentar retardar ao máximo o
avanço da doença
há um dos estudos mais recentes e que
estão mostrando resultados bem
significativos é com o uso das drogas e
que é um canabinóide proveniente no caso
da cannabis que vem mostrando que
conseguem de alguma forma inibe a
acumulação da proteína ao redor dos
neurônios e consegue melhorar muito os
sintomas consegue aliviar muito eles é
bem controverso é bem complicado falar
sobre por que não uma substância
totalmente legalizada e muitas pessoas
confundem a substância com o uso da
droga
mas se houvesse mais investimento num
estudo a fundo sobre isso talvez pudesse
ter uma grande chance para as pessoas
que hoje têm ou pessoas que futuramente
possam vir desenvolver essa doença
uma curiosidade é que o governo
americano ele investe 15 bilhões de
reais em influência do câncer para
estudos e na dose ele só só investe 5
milhões ea comparação com a taxa de
alzheimer e é do câncer que tem bem mais
investimento
por isso talvez que a gente não tem
ainda fundo como curar é o alzheimer e
eu acho que a gente deveria investir
mais porque realmente afeta muitas
pessoas
[Aplausos]